what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation we are doing our first
joint remote or whatever the heck you
call this movie reaction sally say hi to
the citizens of the reject nation hi
she did it she said hi sally right now
has been doing a marvel movie marathon i
think all by the time this video is up
all of the phase one should be up and uh
we were like we should do a joint movie
reaction together but she lives in new
york and um you know when she was out
here we were doing stuff together all
the time i feel like i've seen moments
of spaceballs and like random clips but
i've never seen the have you seen this
movie i've never seen spaceballs i
remember my mom watching it when i was
younger but she said i wasn't allowed to
watch it so i'm assuming it gets raunchy
i've seen like memes i know what makes
fun of star wars so that's all i know
about it it's a hard pg this spaceballs
uh yeah guys uh you can go ahead check
out sally's marvel movie marathon
playlist it's in the description box and
yeti it's on the channel you could also
follow her on her own youtube channel
social media which you guys can do for
us is leave a like leave a damn like
leave a like leave a like do it rlt
spaceball and you can uh subscribe and
click the notification bell to get
notified when uh either one of our
reactions up here on the channel yeah
full length reaction watch as long as we
sync up with the time code available for
super sexy rejects over at our patreon
page and uh thanks to the team of
prepper for helping us edit these down
sally i don't think we've watched the
movie side by side in like eight years
or something like that wasn't it raid
two and there was an earthquake that was
probably the last said sit your ass down
we're finishing this movie
you're like you know what it's part of
the experience it's 4d people
anyway let's get to it
[Music]
spaceball
sounds like the superman theme there
lived
a ruthless race of big
space falls
[Music]
you know you place a couple words this
is a real star wars movie right i'm like
shook this is
this is good
[Music]
classic ominous star wars shot looks
like star fox 64.
[Music]
damn this thing is massive that's what
she said
[Music]
this shot is gonna go
[Laughter]
wow this is
they were like we need to make sure
everyone gets this joke
[Music]
wow holy [ __ ] we're still going
this is the next 80 minutes
now it's 10 jaws
all rise in the presence of dark helmet
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
is there a tie on
yeah
it looks like a dick and balls yes it
does
i can't breathe in this thing we're
approaching planet druidia sir good
i'll call spaceball city and notify
president screw up immediately i already
called him sir he knows everything
you went over my helmet
no no no no no no no please please
please no no no not that
yes
that
wow
look at those effects
you call that a radar screen
no sir we call it mr coffee
care for some i always have coffee when
i watch radar you know that of course i
do sir everybody knows that of course
when will the princess be married within
the hour sir
well i hope it's a long ceremony cause
it's gonna be a short honeymoon
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's actually really really great
timing yeah the
coffee spit here i am i'm sorry i had to
make a pit stop i'm so excited i
couldn't hold my oil
daddy i go through with this i'm sorry
my dear you have to
i like how this is like totally made up
and not an actual star wars plot it's
right
but daddy
i don't love him oh
he's the last prince left in the galaxy
oh no
oh he looks like your ex-boyfriend
he didn't look like that when we were
dating i hope he's not watching
[Music]
daughter of king rome
right past the altar heading down the
ramp
no questions dot get in
[Music]
you know for a spoof comedy they put
together some pretty cool [ __ ]
[Music]
nice matt shot with the carpet rug
[Music]
oh okay so this is like harrison ford
and that's chewbacca you did it sally i
figured it out i cracked it you
recognized them
hello vinny what do you want no no no no
no no
it's what
he wants
oh
pizza hut
ah and his sidekick puke
that's barf bomb
whatever
where's my money that is disturbing a
hundred thousand space bucks by tomorrow
a hundred thousand
oh my god i can't watch that i can't do
it i can't do it the bubbles there's
bubbles you're gonna pay it
or else or else pizza
is gonna send out for you
[Music]
[Music]
that is so gross
will you turn that thing off
what
[Laughter]
that was a really good review
i want something like that
people in la could use that
shall i have snotty beam you down sir is
it safe oh yes sir snotty beamed me
twice last night
great beasties what's happened to his
head it's on backwards this is terrible
do something i'm sorry i said there must
have been a micro converter malfunction
it's got a scottish outfit forget it no
more beaming this time i'm gonna walk
[Laughter]
what's his name that is his name sir
[ __ ] major [ __ ]
how many [ __ ] we got on this ship
anyhow
yo
i knew it i'm surrounded by asthma
keep firing [ __ ]
don't worry daddy hurry
there are laser blasts all around us
i'm scared
who is that actress i don't know i was
trying to figure that out
one princess for one million space bucks
what's she driving a brand new white
mercedes 2001 sel limited edition moon
roof all leather interior i got it at a
very good price i paid cash my cousin
prince murray has a dealership in the
valley
the minute we move in there they're
going to spot us on their radar not if
we jam it radar
about to be
jammed
nice
nicely done
[Laughter]
there's only one
man who would dare give me the raspberry
lone star
[Applause]
scary movie totally ripped that joke off
oh true
i am princess vespa daughter of roland
king of the druids
that's all we needed
a jewish princess
[Music]
we're picking up the outline of a
winnebago
winnebago
lone star
moonstone
prepare ship for light speed no no light
speed is too slow might speed too slow
yes we're gonna have to go right to
ludicrous speed
ludicrous speed sir how you better
buckle up apocalypse
ludicrous speed
go
my brains
are going into my feet
they've gone to plaid
we passed them
what
i was like am i missing something
[Music]
oh
[Music]
wow look at those models
now listen you
you listen on this ship you're to refer
to me as idiot not you captain
i mean you know what i mean
they're still not on the scanner well
keep looking for them
there's no liquid company
nice sound effects guys
wow look at all those rocky movies
there's 12
blazers
i love blazing saddles instant cassettes
they're out in stores before the movie
is finished shook
here it is sir
spaceballs
good work corporal punch it up
what
this is so
i love it prepare to fast forward
preparing to fast forward fast forward
no no go past this pass this part
in fact never play this again try here
stop
what the hell am i looking at when does
this happen in the movie now you're
looking at now
we're it now now go back to then when
now now no i can't why we missed it when
just now
when will then be now
soon
[Laughter]
what is it i don't know i've taken it to
every wise man in the universe and
nobody could tell me what it means
you know what
it's beautiful
oh he got shy
i realize now that love is one luxury a
princess cannot afford
you're probably right
i know now that i must learn to live
without love i guess so
i think he's so creepy
sure you're good without physical
contact
yeah
why is it like repeating everything back
so weird
or kissed
[Music]
[Applause]
virgin alarm
what
how far did it get what did he touch
what did he touch nothing happened what
the hell was that noise that was my
virgin alarm it's programmed to go off
before you do
[Music]
we gotta get moving before dawn because
we're in the middle of a desert and we
aren't gonna get very far once that
blazing sun gets overhead
nice dissolve
are they also spoofing indiana jones
they kind of get that vibe
[Music]
phil oh my god there's some gross jokes
in this movie
well
not surprising i can't go any further
come on nobody
no there's one more doing the goal no
you said that three dunes ago
i got no more left
just roll down
just roll her that's what i would do
what's going on
oh my god
what i love about that is they don't
even look like they're sweating
no
no sunburn either
oh my
gosh wait there's six i i think that's
exactly what they're doing
thank you
did i miss something
when did we get to disneyland
[Music]
this movie's
like a really loud snl sketch
pretty much who dares enter the sacred
and awesome presence of the everlasting
know-it-all
yogurt yogurt
[Music]
oh
oh my god that's terrifying who hasn't
heard of yogurt
yogurt the wine now that we can find a
wizard of oz
you're the one yes
i am the keeper of a crater magics as
the the force no
the schwartz
space balls the dog me
may the schwartz be with you
[Music]
what i have an urgent message from lord
helmut who's lost the princess where
somewhere in the sands of vega tell them
to comb the desert you hear me
comb the desert
yes sir of course the director would put
himself in bed right now attractive
blonde woman
how is that not pg-13 that's probably
why my mom didn't let me watch it found
anything yet
nothing yet sir
capacity prop cop yeah i know i'm like
that's
they really went all out they got three
of them
what about you guys
we ain't found [ __ ]
they didn't know
jesus christ
wise guys you mean what do they know
here let me take a look
[Music]
we're gonna get cancelled watching this
[Music]
there is an actual plot today i know i
was like wait
[Music]
yes hey boss how'd you do this
[Music]
figured out how to use the schwartz so
fast
he's a mary sue you're right sir there's
a secret entrance here
and look at this insignia it's a y
yogurt i hate yogurt even with
strawberries
daddy
is it really you yes my dear
i guarantee it
would i lie
no mess but don't bet
no
fool you
[Laughter]
take them both aboard and put the
princess in my quarter yes sir no
just in case they get hungry
a fortune cookie yes
open it before you eat it
the wise words lone star yes it's me i'm
here to save my girlfriend hi honey
now you are going to die oh oh
oh hey what you doing to my friend the
same thing i'm going to do to you big
boy oh oh
why is he doing that accent
you've never played with dolls greg
he's doing like a jamaican accent or
something
still you get lost you know
you get lost
oh
oh
oh
your helmet is so big
i don't think that joke would farewell
now
i would buy that
i'll put that on my christmas present
list for you
thank you
president screws
i told you never to call me on this wall
this is an unlisted wall oh no
tell them i'll be right there yes sir
nice
and i was waiting for her to look down
when she did i was like there we go
why would you not
if you do not give me the combination to
the air shield dr slotkin will give your
daughter back
her old nose oh god
the combination is
one
one one
two two three two
three three
four five five five
so the combination is
that's the stupidest combination i've
ever had in my life that's the kind of
thing an idiot would have on his luggage
thank you your highness
clay didn't you turn off the whole movie
i must have pressed the wrong button
well put it back up yes sir yes sir
you got to get that thing fixed wow oh
my god
go back to the golf course and work on
your putts
let's go arnold come on
of course you know i'll still have to
bill you for this
i don't think the pg-13 rating was
invented yet okay got it
[Music]
the trouble last thing
she's a base
she's a face
how did you find us no time to talk come
on
we got to move
how'd you do it
put the helmet back on
that would be logical where did the
helmets go
that's our only way out what's wrong oh
i hate these movies
[Music]
[Laughter]
wilhelm scream turn around please
ah
different people
what up
princess you thought you could outwit
the imperious forces
looks like lieutenant dan
i wonder if those were some real stunt
doubles yeah that would have been funny
you hold them off i'll get the door i'm
shooting this thing i hate guns
you shot my hair
[Laughter]
i don't know who she is but she's a
hottie she's great
i'm jealous this would be so fun to film
ship is too big if i walk the movie will
be over
[Laughter]
changing
[Music]
it's turning into like some
person
yeah
it's not just a spaceship
it's a transformer exactly that's what i
was gonna say
changing into a gigantic
made
with a vacuum cleaner
what so that's how they're gonna get the
air out
they're gonna suck it out
[Music]
that's not a bad effect no i look pretty
good
now commence operation
vacuum suck
[Music]
oh no
[Music]
wow
[Music]
it's
it's working
[Music]
oh god can you imagine if a vacuum
actually did that reverse everything out
she's gone from suck to blow
what
jesus
there's so many sex jokes in this movie
it's called space balls
what are we watching
i'm breathing
air
every time i leave l.a
[Laughter]
ain't that a fact yeah
[Music]
is that you my luck
space balls shaving cream
who are you
what are you doing with that this
[Applause]
oh
not so fast
helmet
so at last we meet for the first time
for the last time
i am your father's brother's nephew's
cousin's former roommate what's that
make us
absolutely nuts
prepare to die
nice
nice
you have the ring
and i see your schwartz is as big as
mine
hey
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
i hate it when i get my schwartz twisted
[Music]
yogurt has taught you well
if there's one thing i just yogurt
didn't teach him [ __ ] no
be the best man win
the ring
i can't believe you fell for the oldest
trick in the book
what a goof
what's with you man come on he's
speaking jamaican again
i can't believe it man
why is he doing that
[Music]
i'll try say goodbye to your two best
friends and i don't mean your pals in
the winner bagel
you can see this string did you see the
string
thank you for pressing the self-destruct
button
this ship will self-destruct in three
minutes
nicely done
attention this is colonel sanders in
forward command abandon ship abandon
ship all personnel proceed to escape
pods
there's a ronald mcdonald house
sanders you gotta help me i don't know
what to do i can't make decisions i'm a
president
[Music]
hey that's my escape pod who are you i'm
the bearded lady what are you one of the
freaks
[Music]
what one pod left
and three of us and i'm the president
well boys it's a very lovely ship i
think you should go down with it
goodbye
oh
i would have gone with the bear i mean
what other choice would you have yeah
where is it where is it it's gonna be
here
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
have a nice day thank you
[Music]
we defeated the bad guy
look like they were going to hit teeth
i know right
oh yes they survived
famed half man half pizza was found dead
earlier today in the backseat of his
stretched limo evidently the notorious
gangster became locked in his car and
ate himself to death
good
see did you hear that
pizza kicked the bucket now we don't
have to pay him the million we can keep
it for ourselves
yeah
why is he sad
he's got to return why can't he just
live there with those million dollars
[Music]
that's actually a really beautiful thing
i'm about to say i want to move there
it's gorge
i got it
we all pluto
it was a harry how can you tell he said
from the block you dummies
from the bark
is that the alien crew yeah i think that
is oh my god
oh really oh no
[Music]
oh no
not again
i think they've it's the same reactor
really
am i free
what is happening
[Music]
check please
i'm completely over him
didn't even stay for the wedding just
grabbed his million space bucks and ran
he didn't take the million
whoa oh god to us
he just took 248 space bucks for lunch
gas and tolls
well thanks i'll split it with you no
okay
yogurt
you know that medallion that you wear
around your neck but you don't know what
it means
well here's what it means
it's a royal birth certificate
[Music]
liquid schwartz quick pour it in the
emergency tank right i believe this is
considered one of the greatest plot
twists in movie history yeah i'm like
damn they got like the original makeup
[ __ ] why didn't you tell me he didn't
take the money i didn't think it was
important
may i continue
he asked me not to tell you
don't you see he loves me excuse me i'm
trying to conduct a wedding here which
has nothing to do with love please be
quiet
prince valium do you take princess
vesper to be your lawfully wedding wife
uh-huh princess best you take prince
valiantly your lovely wedded husband uh
well i
i suppose what oh i don't know no
oh look at his suit
that's what this says i'm an
honest-to-god prince
will you marry me yes who are you i'm
the best man
what's your name barf your full name
bartholomew
the short short version
do you
yes do you yes good you're married
kesser
i love you
i love you
he should have said i know
come on that's that's star wars i know
you just said star wars i did
he's kissing with his eyes open
weirdos gross freaky
okay plot
all righty well what'd you think
salamander
let's break this down heavy
heavy duty breakdowns today
uh
non-stop
you know intellectual discussions
about
space balls
you were right when you're like it feels
like one long sketch the minute you said
that i was like yes it but with a really
really high production value like just
that one shot of them coming out of the
nose
it looked like a a real
like practical effect of a huge
structure
yeah coming out of and it was only for
like a few seconds that joke so i'm just
like wow
i i feel like they did a lot of good
scales and real models it felt like um
which was cool for
like a movie that's just like a more
than just a parody of star wars it's
like they got some jokes it seems like
indiana jones some star trek jokes just
like sending some sci-fi movies as well
some fantasy movies it was doing a lot
um
and it was just kind of hovering back
and forth for me
of uh
sometimes it was
just kind of like a little annoying and
then other times it was really funny
because the thing is for me is like
usually with a comedy i'm pretty black
and white about it in the sense of if
it's funny
it's funny
and sometimes not funny but if it's
annoying it's just like annoying to me
from beginning to end
yeah and this wasn't that for me it was
like at times it's annoying and at
the same time it could be really funny
and it didn't stay consistent in either
one for me like i get what you mean
about comedy movies you either love a
movie a comedy movie as you're watching
it or you absolutely hate it and you
have to turn it off but this one
had really great moments and then some
moments where i was like oh that's
definitely like not a joke that i find
funny at all and is a product of its
time
well it's like there were there was a
joke like every it was a joke every
other line was like
they were i think
the role in comedy screenwriting is a
joke um every third it's like that you
have there's a rule of three it's like
every third line has to be a joke is
that the rule is that the rule of comedy
yeah i i took a class in college it was
it was the rule of three they perfected
it they perfected comedy that in order
for it to to be funny he got it gotta be
every third let's it's the rule yeah
yeah there's gotta be did you go to
clown college what the [ __ ] did you do
what you do you always said you took a
comedy class in college yeah we had to
write we had to write a a i had to write
a cold opening of um
of brooklyn nine-nine like an episode oh
nice
wow so we had to like take a show and
write a cold open or write the first i
think it was like six pages of
our own version of that television oh my
god you guys did you go to film school
i in fact i went to the same school as
john
john humphrey
oh [ __ ] that's right i totally forgot
i completely forgot
i was sounding like such an ignorant
[ __ ] did you go to clown college
i literally went to college when i was
doing videos with you it's kind of weird
to feel like there's a specific way a
comedy must be right i mean that makes
sense to me for like a sitcom like you
you're saying brooklyn nine-nine like
yeah i get it you got 22 minutes of
television and
um and so that makes sense to me before
for a movie sometimes it's it's like a
little
it's like okay we don't need to try to
like make everything so sometimes it
just feels like forced or
like like a melt like this mel brooks
and
you know i watch blazing saddles for the
very first time i love blazing saddles
and um
like i like blazing saddles more
but that this me too because this felt
like mel brooks older and doing like the
dad jokes of mel brooks is kind of what
this felt like to me yeah but i know
this movie's beloved uh which so i it's
it's something that i don't i don't know
if it's like new viewers would really
love because it's my first time watching
it so i don't know if it's something
that's like ah
you know what it is let me look this up
real quick i think it was the first
movie to do this the star wars spoof
any spoof i think it was the first movie
no not any spoof but like a first full
length to do a spoof of a of a huge
franchise yeah
because then
scary movie came out and that kind of um
started the snowball effect again of
like doing you know making fun of horror
movies and then they went and made fun
of like a superhero movie um they made
fun of yeah like other genres but this
was the first like sci-fi one well there
was like the naked gun movies there was
also um yeah top top secret was a good
one okay spaceballs came out in
1987 87.
yeah you know it's like there was no
like
i thought the cast was fine but there
was no performer that i really like
truly loved excuse me
the gentleman who was doing all the
sound effects killed me he was great he
knocked out of the park and he didn't
even have a character name
yeah
oh my god it really was his favorite
john he got john the alien with the
chest burster he really got the real
john hurt to return i was like that guy
looks a lot like john hurt
so it's kind of crazy good for them
um so yeah and like seeing rick rick
moranis is always fun uh to see as um
[ __ ] darth hellman is with his
character with but he's always fun and
i'm not used to seeing him play like a
chauvinistic [ __ ] type of character
he's usually more on the sweeter side so
seeing him play like a douchebag was
that was fun to see um
bill pullman as lone star bill pullman's
uh
he's always kind of creeped me out for
some reason he's never been my
favorite actor like i don't know
he's what else was he in he played he
played some role i just oh while you
were sleeping yeah i i i tried watching
that movie and i just didn't find him
very like
appealing to me for a while
i was like i don't think sandra bullock
i don't think he could pull sandra
bullock in real life like that
probably
um i mean he was also the president of
independence day and he always kind of
like creeped me out i don't know what it
is about him
there's something about him where i'm
like i can see you being like
a pervert
it's just like the vibe i get
that's something you think greg when you
don't say
i'm just saying he just seems like he
could be a pervert i'm gonna google it
right now it's funny because i see it
but i'm like that's so mean like
bill pullman pervert
nope there's nothing bad about him
apparently he's a nice guy
i'm sorry apparently he's a
philanthropist and a humanitarian
he's a great human being they weren't my
words
um but yeah greg you never have to be
alone in a room with him that's fine um
but yeah i mean did you like the movie
overall
um it's
i it was i'm glad i could say i've seen
it it didn't have the same effect for me
as blazing saddles though i think in my
head i kept comparing how funny that
movie was and then with this it was like
oh like there were moments but yeah
i think you were coming from
yeah like at least now we can be like
yes we've seen spaceballs because there
was there were a few jokes in them i've
heard from
other people
and i was like okay yeah now i know that
that is from this movie you know what i
mean yeah
yeah
it kind of just made me want to do
sketches again on youtube like
some moments it did have that yeah
because it was like i didn't really find
it
i think what was missing for me was like
some cleverness
uh like a lot of it just sort of you
know what
it reminded there were some moments
where i was like austin powers did this
joke better i feel like there were some
similarities but austin powers like
definitely
is like on a whole other level it's like
an advanced version of this movie yeah i
think austin powers is brilliant like i
i think that's me too it's it really
becomes a real film
while being like a genre spoof film you
know those are my favorite kind of
spoofs and to me this was like
a a lot of the jokes were feeling like a
little cheap to me i feel i feel i feel
bad to say because i know how popular
and loved this movie is but i was like i
don't know this kind of felt like a
little cheap to me with a lot of the
jokes but then again that's what i mean
it was so intermittent sometimes it was
so funny though
i think mel brooks was like i have a
[ __ ] ton of money i can put into it
let's just you know what i mean like
it's a really expensive youtube sketch
that's kind of what i like thought of
yeah i want to see if if uh austin
powers was inspired at all by this movie
because
i could see some similarities for sure
perhaps especially with embracing a
genre
no i really i'm not i think it's just
part of the you know the
spoof genre you know it just made me
want to watch austin powers that's
pretty much what
i did think of it at times especially
when outer space and the human uh
when it turned into a transformer that
was times where i was thinking like dr
evil in space
but yeah yeah i mean the low brow humor
the
the
vulgarity the crudeness
of it there was this real hit or miss
for me like from beginning to end and uh
some of the acting took me out of it i'm
not gonna say what actors because i'm
i'm an actor too i wouldn't you want to
be respectful
yes
some of the acting i thought didn't it
took me out of it it was like either
overacting or the acting was weird and
like didn't match you know what i mean
i mean sometimes it felt like the
they were really playing up the comedy a
lot it was just like it was like too
i don't know
it's i don't want to be too harsh on it
at the same time it was like it was
either really funny to me or it was
annoying it was it was one of the two it
was either annoying or really funny and
it just kept hopping back and forth
between them both which means that
brilliance of mel brooks would still
occasionally shine through yet
um it had some it had some good moments
but i don't know real hitters but i
don't think it's one i would like watch
again
no i'm i'm okay with this damn like have
it on in the background while i'm like
cleaning or something wow that sounds
really mean
well i'm on rotten tomatoes right now
i just went on it just to see what it's
got and it's got like an eight i just
lost a page one second
one second
yeah it's uh 56 on critics but at a
250 000
audience score
83
that's really good
for 250 000 people 250 000 plus that's
insane that's really it's also a
nostalgic movie too like when this came
out star wars was like at its peak i'm
trying to think of a comparison it's
like if someone made a movie right now
making fun of stranger things
or like a whole show if someone made a
whole show making fun of stranger things
i feel like would be freaking hilarious
because it's so popular right now but i
feel like 20 30 years later like people
wouldn't find it that funny yeah
i think the thing i i think yeah i think
thing i appreciate about most is the
fact that they
they they actually built a lot of
costumes and stuff and prac and and did
a lot of like cool practical
the production value was insane i was
shocked especially for a spoof comedy i
was like damn this is really good it
seemed like they had to work around a
lot of licensing rights
[Laughter]
change enough
but yeah did you ever see did you ever
see galaxy quest yeah it's a great one i
love that one that's also like what kind
of would it remind me of but
yeah that's a great movie i love that
movie i'm always i think movies
brilliant and underappreciated
i agree anyway sally we should close
this out i love how you've been doing
the marvel movies and then we went for
the lowest brow
spoof movie that we both thought was
just okay
and now people are gonna be like wow you
guys don't like a classic we had to run
a test experiment if we had some of us
like let's do it on something that's
like just funny and we had to figure out
this is our first time working with it
was fun i think it was fun it was a fun
movie i had a fun time i had fun it was
fun watching with you your your pleasure
to have as a companion for this comedy
piece
anyway guys um follow sally on the
socials
oh can i can't wait a second
you didn't link my youtube link in the
last
video gregory
uh
that people were like where's her
channel i was like let me check okay
john like we went to the same film
school like let's blame john
he's not in the room blame john
okay i will because you know i have so
many new videos out
there so i need to no
are you making such a push
what the [ __ ]
you're making such a push for something
that you barely don't have enough
follow her follow her as soon as you can
um just do it yeah yeah anyway guys
thanks for being here
and uh
we'll catch you all soon follow sally on
at any link in the description box
is that neither schwartz be with you is
there is there anything else to say that
you want me to say
no let's just say may the shorts be with
you may the schwartz be with you
oh my god sally you changed your profile
pic on your on your on your channel
it's beautiful
huh
it's beautiful it's great
thank
you i like how your demo reel thumbnail
says comedic and you got a real crying
face of yours
yeah i need to say that
like that is not what i thought when i
saw like oh she's got a dramatic but
you'll click on it because you'd be like
what did she
label this wrong and then it'll get me
now
all right we're really ending now
all right bye everyone bye everyone bye
[Music]
you